[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 l'hebdo une émission pour
revenir sur l'actualité départementale
de la semaine lé titre de ce vendredi 22
septembre direction las vegas deux
startups ont remporté le challenge
paris-saclay cls le 2018 la finale se
tenait hier au café de la royale factory
à versailles saisie vinoir
représenteront le département au
consumer electronics show en janvier
prochain
il concerne environ 13% de la population
française le handicap a fait l'actualité
avec un comité interministériel sur le
sujet cette semaine un collectif créé à
plaisir tente d'alerter les pouvoirs
publics et politiques sur plusieurs
inégalités existantes
andy actifs france nous recevons là
l'une de ses fondatrices isabelle
olivier et puis dans le reste de
l'actualité locale retour notamment sur
la semaine européenne de la mobilité et
sur la journée des parlementaires à
satory
c'était hier soir la finale du trophée
paris saclay cs 2018 finale qui se
tenait à la royale factory à versailles
s'est organisée par la cci versailles
yvelines
à la clé des billets pour le consumer
electronics show qui se déroulera en
janvier prochain à las vegas c'est l'un
des plus grands rassemblements mondiaux
et deux yvelinois sont distingués pour
partir à las vegas ce retour sur la
soirée avec nicolas landry et mélanie
poker en janvier ils seront à las vegas
l'un est basé à montigny le bretonneux
le second est originaire de rambouillet
lamberth renora et team audi le kent
sont les lauréats du challenge par les
sacs les crs grâce à l'invention le giro
livre c'est une nouvelle forme de
de mobilité c'est un nouveau type de
fauteuil roulant s'est basé sur un
gyropode donc c'est on connaît de marque
segway par exemple c'est une plateforme
sur deux roues et qu'on contrôle avec
son centre de gravité
non là on l'adapté pour laurent
universel pour permettre à des personnes
à mobilité réduite de se dépasser aussi
bien assis que debout c'est un chargeur
sans fil
donc c'est un pad qui econnaît geek est
branché sur secteur et sur lequel on
peut recharger tous ces appareils
simultanément on peut charger 4 à 5 ces
appareils simplement les équipes en un
petit autocollant et on les posant sur
ce pad avec six autres candidats ils ont
eu sept minutes pour convaincre le jury
et le public
ce sont des entreprises qui ont moins de
8 ans à l'origine du concours la chambre
de commerce et d'industrie versailles
yvelines
le cms las vegas c'est le regroupement
de deux très grands salons au salon
automobile salon de l'électronique de
différents types de salon de la
communication donc ce sont des gens ce
sont des gens qui vont pouvoir accéder à
cette immensité à ce salon immense dans
un environnement où avant tout l'intérêt
c'est le business c'est à dire votre
giraud lift m'intéresse je sais moi
d'ores et déjà que je peux vous en
commander temps parce que j relifté
énergie square poseront leurs valises
aux états unis le 9 janvier prochain
la cci les a nommés experts las vegas de
la communauté open innove dans le reste
de l'actualité se tenait cette semaine
un comité interministériel sur le
handicap
premier du genre sous le quinquennat
macron mercredi le premier ministre
edouard philippe a fait plusieurs
annonces sur le sujet environ 13 % de la
population française est concernée par
le handicap on accueille sur ce plateau
isabelle olivier bonsoir vous est
cofondatrice du collectif andy actifs
france créée au début de l'année à
plaisir par six mamans dont vous faites
partie regroupe plusieurs associations
d'enfants handicapés de parents
concernés par ce handicap
vais vous faire réagir sur ces annonces
d'edouard philippe dans cette émission
mais d'abord parlons du collectif et de
ses combats il a été lancée juste avant
tout les échéances électorales de cette
année je pense aux présidentielles aux
législatives aux sénatoriales qui arrive
aussi dimanche il y avait une vraie
volonté 8 d'alerté au moment de ces
scrutins
oui en fait le but de ce collectif à la
base c'était de d'alerter tous les
candidats à la présidentielle sur les
problématiques que rencontrent et les
parents d'enfants handicapés ainsi que
les adultes handicapés on s'est aperçu
que pendant la campagne présidentielle
on faisait pratiquement pas parlé de du
handicap
du coup on a créé ce collectif et on a
essayé de contacter pratiquement tous
les candidats à la présidentielle vous
avez d'ailleurs lancé une pétition et
vous l'avez transmises aux différents
candidats
avec ce constat alarmant l'aide et la
prise en charge des enfants souffrant
d'un handicap est défaillante en france
d'après une enquête menée par votre
collectif les enfants et adultes
handicapées bénéficiant en moyenne d'une
séance de rééducation par semaine soit
deux heures en tout c'est trop peu
aujourd'hui
alors effectivement c'est à peu près
deux heures de rééducation par semaine
alors qu'en réalité il faudrait
plusieurs heures par jours de
rééducation pour qu'on puisse espérer
qu'un enfant gagne un peu plus
d'autonomie d'autonomie avec deux heures
par semaine ça n'est pas possible et
c'est pour l'art et pour cette raison si
que beaucoup de parents partent à
l'étranger pour faire des stages de
rééducation intensive pour retrouver
cette ces thérapies qu'ils permettent
aux enfants de faire d énormément de
progrès grandir en bout dans un seau n'y
a peut-être pas aussi assez de lieux
d'accueil en france un seul constat
manque énormément de structure il manque
aussi de formation au niveau des
thérapeutes
la france ne s'est pas non plus
intéressé aux thérapies qui s'est
effectué en europe et aux états unis par
rapport aux rééducation ce qui fait que
les parents se tournent vers l'étranger
justement pour pouvoir bénéficier de ces
thérapies on voit d'ailleurs votre
petite fille anaïs à l'image vous êtes
la maman
de cette fille qui a subi à la naissance
de graves lésions cérébrales qui
l'handicape aujourd'hui lourdement elle
suit des thérapies des stages réguliers
à barcelone dans la clinique i sensys
finalement il n'y a pas d'autre choix
que d'aller à l'étranger aujourd'hui on
est obligé pour faire soigner pour faire
aussi voyez vous soigner son enfant
mais si on veut lui faire faire un des
stages de rééducation intensive ça n'est
absolument pas possible en france
parce qu'en france on est limité par
parler las condes la sécurité sociale
qui par exemple pour une séance de kiné
nous limite à 30 minutes alors que quand
on va à santis ou quand on va en pologne
on a trois à quatre heures de
rééducation l'art jour la sécurité
sociale ne peut pas financer ce genre de
rééducation intensive c'est ça c'est à
double tranchant finalement l objet de
partir à l'étranger et peut-être des
fois de sacrifier des vacances d'été
tant qu'on peut passer avec son enfant
et en plus ces thérapies ne sont pas
remboursés puisque à l'étranger voilà
non elles ne sont pas du tout remboursés
c'est la raison pour laquelle les
parents créent des associations comme
nous mêmes nous avons créé l'association
analyse du rêve à l'espoir qui nous
permet de récolter des fonds
donc aussi bien pour financer ces
thérapies mais également pour payer le
matériel médical qui est très onéreux et
peu remboursés
j'allais venir sur ce sujet le matériel
très coûteux entre un équipement par
exemple un siège auto pour enfants pour
un enfant valider un enfant handicapé
il ya une différence de prix exorbitants
qui a cédé fois plus cher en fait on on
prend un siège de base qui peut coûter
250 euros un bon siège de base dans le
marché si on y rajoute quelques options
une base pivotante pour permettre aux
parents de ne pas trop se faire mal de
dos pour mettre son enfant dans la
voiture un plot d'abduction pour éviter
à l'enfant de glisser est un art mais un
harnais de sécurité
le siège auto revient à 2000 euros donc
oui c'est il ya une différence est
énorme et c'est en fait énormément
d'abus parce qu'en fait les sociétés qui
fabriquent les
les sièges auto ne propose pas dans le
commerce des sièges auto avec des bases
pivotante c'est c'est uniquement des as
par ailleurs qui le font et on se
demande pourquoi alors je le disais en
début d'émission le comité
interministériel du handicap se tenait
mercredi il s'est conclu par une annonce
importante du premier ministre edouard
philippe la hache l'allocation adultes
handicapés sera revalorisée et devance
ul pour les personnes en situation de
handicap
elle passera à 900 euros en novembre
2019 contre 810 euros aujourd'hui
ce sera à 860 euros dès novembre 2010
huit augmentations bien accueillie par
les bénéficiaires yvelinois même s'il
reste encore beaucoup à faire écouter
hélas je trouve qu'il ya encore beaucoup
trop de choses qui n'ont pas été traités
par le gouvernement justement gens que
je voulais juste parler les dés de la
dotation d'état qui va être papa
supprimer totalement mais très très très
réduits ce qui fait d'eux on parle de
300 millions de cette année qui est
quand même été retiré dans les
collectivités ce qui va empêcher les
communes aggravation dans les communes
pour la mise en accessibilité
alors qu'on attend ça fait des années et
des années qu'on attend on est vraiment
déçu de cette de cette chose qu'on ne
prend pas en compte la chaux concerne en
france près d'un million de personnes en
situation de handicap alors isabelle
olivier d'autres mesures ont été aussi
annoncé par le gouvernement
spécifiquement à destination des jeunes
la création par exemple de 250 classes
ulis des unités localisées pour
l'inclusion scolaire ce sont à des
dispositifs de scolarisation destiné aux
élèves en situation de handicap avec un
un enseignement adapté c'est une bonne
mesure où il aurait fallu aller plus
loin encore pour le gouvernement alors
c'est déjà une bonne mesure parce que
malheureusement il ya beaucoup d'enfants
qui ne peuvent pas
accédez à une classe normale pour des
raisons de handicap sensoriel par
exemple ils ne peuvent pas travailler
avec d une classe de 30 élèves
donc c'est une bonne mesure par contre
moi je voudrais mettre l'accent sur la
formation des professionnels la
formation handicap puisque chaque élève
à son sa spécificité et il ne peut pas
apprendre de la même façon qu'un autre
élève qui n'a pas du tout le même
handicap formation des avs parizon
formation des avs et formation des
professionnels des enseignants
il ya vraiment une lacune à ce niveau là
et moi je connais beaucoup de mamans qui
se plaignent de leurs avs parce qu'elles
n'ont pas du tout déjà le nom le niveau
scolaire et n'ont pas été formés pour
appréhender le handicap de leur enfant
c'est avait cinq sont des adultes
accompagnants pour ses enfants
handicapés alors le ministre de
l'éducation nationale jean michel
blanquer avait annoncé au moment de sa
nomination faire du handicap l'une de
ses priorités
il avait annoncé 80 mille adultes
accompagnants dont cinquante mille avs
ces auxiliaires de vie dont vous parliez
où est le problème aux autres ce chiffre
c'est peut-être le manque de formation
vous le disais un instant il faut encore
accentuée avs qui sont mises en place
mais qui n'ont pas été formés ou
handicaps de l'enfant dont elles vont
s'occuper et je trouve ça extrêmement
alarmant puisque un enfant à des besoins
bien spécifiques bien particulier chaque
handicap est différent et on ne peut pas
gérer un enfant lambda avec un handicap
moteur comme un enfant qu il ya d une
déficience mentale ou d'autres handicaps
donc il est vraiment important de former
ces avs de leur donner les moyens
d'aider ces enfants
votre action autre annonce pardon sur
laquelle je voulais vous faire réagir
c'est la création aussi dans un service
civique pour l'intégration des personnes
handicapées à l'université alors le
premier ministre annonce emile service
civique dès 2018 et 2000 l'année
suivante c'est qu'en pensez vous de
cette mesure c'est aussi ça va dans le
bon sens là je trouve que oui c'est
aussi une
une bonne initiative mais on espère plus
ce n'est pas suffisant puisque ça fait
des années que le handicap est laissé
pour compte
il ya vraiment vraiment énormément de
travail le chantier en vrai 1ère en
réalité est titanesque
si on veut vraiment aider les personnes
en situation de handicap
eux sont aussi primordiaux pour les
personnes atteintes d'un handicap visuel
sont les chiens guides d'aveuglés
jusqu'à dimanche une semaine nationale
leur est consacrée à l'occasion pour les
écoles d'échangés avec le public à buc
le centre d'élevage et d'éducation des
chiens guides de paris recherche des
familles d'accueil leur rôle est
essentiel dans leur formation pour la
formation du show à camille lambert a
rencontré mais wells est une chienne
d'un an qui aidera bientôt une personne
malvoyante
mais wayne non ce n'est encore qu'une
élève mais à onze mois mais ouais se
débrouille commune de pro rester à sa
place ne pas courir auprès de ses
congénères et marcher au pied un
enseignement complet pour faire d'elle
un bon chien guide
agnès sa famille d'accueil suit ses
progrès depuis ces trois mois est arrivé
mais well donc au mois de février juste
avant le départ en vacances au ski
donc elle a commencé à arriver trois
quatre jours et les parties tout de
suite avec qui nous à la montagne
et en fait depuis le début se passe
vraiment très très bien c'est vraiment
une très bonne élève
bon moi je suis un peu pendant subjugué
par les capacités et les compétences
qu'elle peut avoir est bien le rôle
d'agnès dans la formation de meiway elle
est essentielle c'est elle qui lui
apprend les bases de l'éducation et la
familiarise avec d'autres environnements
la futur chien guide est suivi par un
éducateur bientôt mais où elle passera
six mois à l'école de buc
elle sera ensuite remise à une personne
déficiente visuelle en fonction de son
caractère
la personne qui s'occupe des dossiers
des déficients visuels et qui les
connaît arrive déjà à faire un peu à
celui-là il irait bien cette personne là
on va essayer en attendant quillan qu'il
en est du casse ont baissé en termes de
rythme en terme de finesse que ça passe
et puis apprendre à gagner 0 mise notre
problème à l'heure actuelle c'est
effectivement que nos déficients visuels
ils sont en attente de deux ans environ
avant d'avoir un chien guide
parce que l'éducation prend énormément
de temps chaque année les chiens guides
de paris re met 45 de leurs compagnons
encore 120 personnes sont en attente
ces chiots donc quelques mois mais eux
aussi deviendront de véritables guides
pour leurs futurs maîtres l'école
recherche des familles d'accueil pour en
prendre soin isabelle olivier on le voit
dans ce sujet tout l'important sein des
familles d'accueil pour ces chiens
guides qui accompagneront ensuite des
personnes aveugles
c'est aussi primordial outre les
annonces qui peuvent être faites par des
politiques aussi par les pouvoirs
publics que des français lambda porte
aussi leur aide soit bénévoles aussi
dans l'action en pour l'aide aussi des
personnes handicapées tout à fait en
fait on s'est rendu compte que beaucoup
de personnes étaient sensibles au
handicap notamment des personnes de
notre entourage
mais on s'est aperçu qu'il y avait
beaucoup aussi de gens qui se portaient
volontaires pour un pour aider les gens
et moi j invite j'ai envie d'inviter les
les familles et les amis qui dans leur
entourage ont des personnes en situation
de handicap à aller vers elle à leur
témoigner de l'intérêt parce que on est
souvent isolées et en fait il est
vraiment important que l'on garde le
contact avec l'extérieur donc par le
biais de bd mollahs mais aussi dit
simplement par la famille par les amis
dernière question revient à votre
collectif qu'elles sont finalement les
prochaines échéances pour le collectif
andy actifs france il ya eu tout
récemment je crois une réunion avec le
le cabinet de la secrétaire d'état en
charge de la santé l'eau du handicap du
handicap voilà c'est ça nous sommes nous
avons été reçus jeudi dernier par
virginie magnan donc la directrice du
cabinet du secrétaire d'état au handicap
on lui a exposé nos problématiques
concernant la prise en charge
rééducative dont on a parlé en début de
journal d'entretien on lui a exposé
aussi le problème du matériel médical
ainsi que le travail et les aidants
familiaux
elle nous a promis de nous intégrer dans
une commission en charge spécifiquement
du polyhandicap donc on attend cette
date d'intégration mois en parallèle
j'avais contacté la député de ma
circonscription qui est florence grange
us était la deuxième circonscription des
walis qui a été très sensible à aux
activités du collectif et elle veut nous
aider et l envie de mener une enquête
justement sur ces problèmes de santé
donc je vais devoir travailler avec elle
et essayez de
notamment d'évaluer le nombre de
personnes qui partent à l'étranger pour
se soigner
s'il avait le l'idée d'avoir été avec
nous je le rappelle cofondatrice du
collectif andy actifs france et pour
plus d'informations on peut se rendre
peut-être sur la page facebook du
collectif voilà on a une page facebook
qui s'appelle collectif andy actifs
france elle est privée mais si vous
souhaitez rentrer il suffit de le
demander et on vous ouvrira la porte
volontiers merci d'avoir été avec nous
on passe tout de suite au reste de
l'actualité locale
l'actualité politique de la semaine
marquée par la crise au sein du front
national et le départ du vice président
françois florian pardon florian
philippot le départ donc du
vice-président au niveau local la partie
le parti a opéré quelques changements
dit fédération à départementale ont un
nouveau patron dont celle des yvelines
est la conseillère régionale mathilde
andrew et 32 ans a été nommé secrétaire
départemental du fn 78 à l'ex candidate
aux législatives remplace françois
simeoni en poste depuis mai 2016 et dans
ce contexte de tension au fn mathilde
endroit est juge être la plus à même de
fédérer autour d'elle et toujours été
très adepte du bas du dialogue de
l'unité de tous les patriotes au delà
même des sensibilités ou des sociologies
et qui peuvent être très diverses et
pour cela il est enfin les élus sont
très intéressantes à ce niveau là parce
que c'est aussi une diversité dans la
géographie une diversité dans les files
vous avez des délits comme trappe les
mureaux mais vous avez versailles et
puis vous avez aussi leur succès des
petites communes de campagne après
koutali ruralité
donc voilà c'est fait diversité là il
faut savoir parler à tous ces jours là
faut savoir aussi parler à toutes les
tendances et et voilà je pense que j'ai
aussi été choisi pour ces raisons ce
mardi nous étions au camp militaire de
versailles satory des députés de la
nouvelle commission de défense nationale
ont été invités sur le site l'armée de
terre a présenté à cette occasion son
armement et ses différentes actions
menées sur le territoire français à
l'étranger
michael et demi d'euros l'armée de terre
l'opération séduction sur le camp
militaire de versailles satory pour la
première fois les responsables ont
invité ce mardi 19 septembre les
nouveaux députés de la commission
défense nationale un groupe renouvelé à
90 % en juin dernier on a un vrai défi
relationnel et d'acculturation vis-à-vis
de ces nouveaux députés et ensuite parce
que on va sans doute écrire une nouvelle
page
de notre histoire militaire avec un
regard tourné sur la remontée en
puissance de nos forces
et donc c'est un projet qu'on va
construire ensemble les élus ont pu voir
des blindés des drones des
démonstrations de déminage des dizaines
d'armes dans le plus ancien nous avons
le 2 qui est un fusil de tireur de
précision et nous avons la minime une
mitrailleuse légère ici qui toutes les
deux sont en dotation maintenant depuis
plus de 20 ans dans nos armées au total
cinq ateliers de 20 minutes étaient
organisées sur la baptiser un programme
nécessaire sur les 30 députés présents
quand on est à la commission de la
défense nationale et des forces armées
et il est important de savoir à quoi
correspondent ces forces d'orner où on
voit ici des matériels qui servent à nos
forces armées
et puis on peut échanger avec les
militaires sur leurs préoccupations et
leurs besoins c'est très important puis
ça nous permet de voir l'évolution de
nous impliquer de pouvoir en parler avec
que encore plus de fierté
les députés devraient voter dans les
prochains mois une hausse du budget de
la défense de 1,6 milliard d'euros par
an sur l'ensemble du quinquennat
les chiffres qui pourraient permettre à
la france d'avoir la première armée
européenne et la deuxième au monde selon
le président emmanuel macron depuis
lundi c'est la semaine européenne de la
mobilité elle incite à réfléchir sur de
nouvelles manières de se déplacer le but
étant de faire changer les comportements
50 franciliens se sont par exemple
lancer dans le défi trois semaines sans
voitures organisée par la mairie de
paris
objectif se passer de son véhicule et
n'utiliser que des transports de
substitution
mélanie poker et camille lambert ont
suivi l'un des candidats qui fait le
trajet tous les matins pour venir
travailler à guyancourt
ce geste c'est devenu une habitude pour
florent prendre le train déplier son
vélo électrique une routine installé
depuis une semaine
comme une cinquantaine de participants
il s'est lancé dans le défi trois
semaines sans voiture j'adopte la
multimodalité
donc c'est à dire que je prends mon je
prends mon vélo de chez moi jusqu'à la
gare montparnasse
ensuite je prends un jeu pendant le ter
qui arrive à la gare de versailles
chantiers ici et ensuite je réutilise ce
vélo dont qui est électrique pour faire
les 8 derniers kilomètres qui me sépare
de mon au travail donc un transport je
mettais à peu près une heure dix 1h15 en
voiture une heure vingt à peu près par
par trajet donc x 2 aujourd'hui
là avec le vélo train vélo je mets à peu
près 55 9 un gain de temps et une source
de pollution en moins
le vélo électrique permet aussi de moins
se fatiguer il est prêté par
l'association we move partenaires de
l'opération
les coaches reste en contact avec les
candidats pour se soutenir et régler les
différents problèmes rencontrés malgré
un souci de crevaisons et une panne
florent reste convaincu j'hésitais déjà
avant le défi je me posais la question
est là le fait d'en avoir un en prêt
pendant trois semaines a fini de
convaincre et ça va être mais un mec
futurs investissements
dès que le porte-monnaie le permet pour
ce type de modèle il faudra compter dans
les 800 euros certains peuvent aller
jusqu'à 2000 la mairie de paris
organisatrice du défi offre une
subvention pour les acheteurs côté
culture c'est une scène célèbre et
mythique des yvelines le théâtre
montansier de versailles célèbre cette
année son 200 40e anniversaire au
programme des conférences des lectures
et des représentations et une exposition
elle a débuté ce week-end le week-end
dernier à l'occasion à des journées du
patrimoine la découverte avec mélanie
poquet
le théâtre montansier c'est avant tout
une histoire de femmes
la première marguerite brunet dit
mademoiselle montansier elle crée ce
théâtre qui prendra son nom inaugurée le
18 novembre 1777 par louis saez c'est un
théâtre qui est la particularité d'être
entre la ville et la cour c'est ce qui
fait sa spécificité il est d'abord
situer géographiquement entre la ville
de versailles et le parc du château
et il accueille au sein du public à la
fois des membres de la cour et dé
versailles et qui viennent assister une
programmation extrêmement riche
près de 180 objets retrace l'histoire de
ce lieu peut être moins connu que
l'opéra royal ou le petit théâtre de la
reine des documents d'époque issus des
collections de la ville dont une lettre
écrite durant la révolution
dans cette lettre au moment où la
montansier est en prison elle essaie de
se justifier auprès dès révolutionnaires
et elle va inventer prétendre qu'elle a
était révolutionnaire avant la lettre en
accueillant les parisiennes au théâtre
de versailles durant les journées
d'octobre le 20e siècle est lui aussi
marqué par une femme marcelle
tassencourt qui le dirigera avec son
mari thierry monnier de 1961 à 1992
marcel tassin cours était à la fois
comédienne metteur en scène elle a été
vraiment une passeuse de théâtre à
versailles en étant à la fois la
directrice du théâtre elle a enseigné au
conservatoire et la forme et un certain
nombre d'élèves qui sont aujourd'hui
assez assez célèbre certains comédiens
d'autres noms comme françois de mazières
l'actuel maire de versailles ou bien
encore muriel mayette qui dirige
la villa médicis à rome le théâtre
montansier se dévoile à travers ses
programmations ses succès ses scandales
ou encore ces rénovations
un anniversaire fêté aux archives
communales de la ville le théâtre
montansier bien sûr parmi les nombreux
édifices et monuments yvelinois dit à zi
6 parfois en péril qu'il convient
d'entretenir à ce propos le maire de
versailles françois de mazières vient
d'interpeller la française des jeux
elle et lui demande la création d'un
tirage spécial du loto pour financer la
restauration des sites en danger
l'édile eux militent par exemple pour
des jeux à gratter à l'éffigie des
monuments célèbres une proposition utile
à ses yeux dans un contexte de baisse
des financements publics du sport 7,8
l'hebdo jusqu'à dimanche le tennis-club
de plaisir organise un tournoi futures
plus de 600 joueurs et 5000 spectateurs
répondent présent chaque année
parmi eux des futures pépites du tennis
français reportage de mickael miro
c'est le troisième plus gros tournoi de
tennis en ile-de-france la 27ème édition
de l'open de plaisir se déroule jusqu'au
24 septembre au tennis club de la
commune cette année plus de 600 joueurs
venus de toute l'europe s'affrontent sur
les clo
les matches sont très disputées les
joueurs ça vont gagner quelques points
atp qui vont leur permettre de défaire
des trois challengers demain et
peut-être demain des grands chelems
donc tout ça c'est une évidence et c'est
pour cette raison que ce tournoi me
plaît bien c'est le sport de haut niveau
qui a son visage naturel si je puis dire
avec sa dotation à 25000 dollars le
rendez-vous est intégré au futur la 6è
catégorie des tournois de tennis
déjà on a des arbitres à la déchetterie
après c'est un futur en ait des
changements de balle on a des serviettes
des bouteilles d'eau ça a fait on est un
peu comme sur un mini un mini rolland ou
university crs mangera pas et on est
considérés comme des très bons joueurs
donc ça fait toujours plaisir
sur le plan sportif le tournoi est
réputé pour faire éclore des talents
l'événement a révélé de nombreux
professionnels tricolore
c'est quoi les futurs champions de
demain li tsonga les mahut et c'est les
llodra et compagnie sont passés par là
donc nous avons les futurs champions de
demain
la future pépite du tennis français se
trouve peut-être sur les courts cette
année si vous voulez les voir à l'oeuvre
et finales sont programmées ce dimanche
24 septembre à partir de 13h30 sur les
courts plaisir ouah c'est la fin de ce
set 8 l'hebdo vous retrouverez dès la
semaine prochaine à la présentation à
nicolas quere lovitz noms se retrouvent
lundi pour le 7-8 journal sur tv 78 très
bon week-end à tous
[Musique]